Why is it so hard
to change the direction
of our civilization?
I'd like to suggest
that what's missing at this point
is not more facts and information
or even technology.
We have more than enough.
What's missing is insight.
My teacher, Zen master Thich Nhat Hanh,
has said that if we haven't yet
changed our way of living,
it's because the awakening
isn't strong enough.
We can't hope to change the world
if we can't change our own way
of seeing things,
our consciousness.
But how can we do this?
In the Zen tradition,
we know that awakening doesn't happen
only with the intellect.
We need to engage our whole being
right in the heart of the present moment.
And a very simple way to do this
is with the practice of mindful walking,
a powerful meditation
that doesn't require
hard labor or even extra time.
Do you remember the first steps
you took outside this morning?
The feel of the ground underfoot,
the fall of the light,
the quality of the air.
Do you remember
the first tree on your way?
Life is there for us, but the question is,
are we there for life?
Perhaps this morning we had something
more important to do.
Perhaps we were in a hurry.
Many of us have a feeling
that we are running out of time.
But when we rush to do something,
are we saving time
or are we losing it?
There is a lot that is urgent,
but in order to take
the kind of radical, decisive action
that our planet is calling for,
we need to be fully present,
grounded and alert,
fearless and free.
It is our way of being
that has got us into our current crises,
and it is our way of being
that can get us out.
Mindful walking can help.
We really feel the contact
between our feet and the ground.
And we enjoy the harmony
between our breathing
and our steps.
With each step, we arrive into our body,
into the present moment.
And we become fascinated by the
whole experience of walking.
And for those of us who are
physically unable to walk,
perhaps we are in a wheelchair,
we enjoy the experience
of moving through space.
And we open up our senses to the sky,
to the trees, to the people around us,
or simply to the hum of life in the city.
And we have a chance to wake up
to what is going on, in us and around us.
And in the Zen tradition,
we also use questions to help us wake up.
To help spark awakening.
And today I would like to offer you three.
The first question is:
Who are you?
Say you're walking to do something.
Perhaps something very important.
Something that may be
the right thing to do
but very hard.
Ask yourself.
Who is walking to do this?
Can you see that you are, in fact,
an entire lineage of parents,
grandparents and ancestors?
We carry all of them within us.
Their qualities and their weaknesses.
Their hopes, their regrets, their fears.
Each one of us is in some way
an ambassador of our species.
And as we walk, we have a chance
to activate the best of ourselves.
The qualities of awakening.
Endurance.
Compassion.
Generosity.
Fearlessness and hope.
And going further, as we walk, we realize
that we embody millions
of years of evolution.
Each one of us is nothing less
than a representative of the planet.
A child of the Earth.
In this very moment,
we are all made of Earth, sun and stars.
Mountains and rivers,
savannahs and rainforests.
It is impossible for us to be
without all these elements.
And realizing this is to see
with the insight of interbeing.
This isn't just intellectual knowledge.
But the living insight that you and I,
we are much more than we think.
And this is an immense source
of love and strength
as we take action in the here and now.
Which brings us to question number two.
Where are you?
Are you here?
Are you now?
Do you feel at home in yourself,
relaxed and at ease?
Or is there still some restlessness,
perhaps a little agitation?
We may feel distracted, preoccupied.
There are those who say
we are too much in the present,
not planning enough for the future.
But there's a difference between being
alert and awake to what is going on
and being lost in our work or projects,
or drowning ourselves in consuming
to cover up, escape from or numb ourselves
to what is actually happening.
Training our body and mind
to be fully present in the here and now
is essential to our survival
and to the future we are creating.
It is in the present
and only in the present
that we can truly nourish our happiness
and handle and take care of our pain
and our suffering.
For example, in this moment,
if each of us takes time
to really breathe in
and come back to our body,
we may find tension.
And right now, on an out breath,
we have a chance to release that tension.
This is possible right away.
If we come back to ourselves
in this moment
and we find sadness,
we have a chance to embrace it.
If we find fear,
anger, despair,
we have a chance to accompany it,
to be with it
and to look deeply
into what it is telling us.
Our suffering contains within it
the suffering of our world.
The violence, the destruction,
the discrimination and exploitation
that is going on right now
across our planet.
We are doing real harm
to one another and to all species.
And the more we realize this,
the more we awaken to this,
we want to do something to help,
to transform the situation.
But this requires a tremendous
source of energy.
And where can we ever find enough energy?
In the Buddhist tradition,
we know that our intention,
our deepest aspiration,
is an immense source of energy.
Which brings us to question number three.
What do you want?
What do you really want?
What is most important to you?
This is not only about doing,
this is also about being.
It is possible to be firmly rooted
in the present moment,
and yet motivated,
energized by a deep desire,
a deep love to contribute
something positive.
And wherever we choose
to make our contribution,
our task is to do our best in that spot
and we will have peace.
Even the simplest act born from love
resonates without limit.
So we're walking.
And we can arrive into our life
at every step.
And we get to ask ourself,
Is this how I want to live my life?
Life is short,
and each one of us needs to identify
and nurture our deepest aspiration,
rekindle it if necessary
and find a community of friends and allies
who share the same dream.
And with the insight of interbeing,
we see that we're not a small me
realizing our dream,
but a vast us.
And we arrive at our destination
in every step.
So who am I?
Where am I?
And what do I want?
The act of asking these three questions
in the heart of our daily life,
as we walk,
will help us to wake up.
Because the fact is,
if we keep going
in the direction we are going,
there is no doubt
our civilization will end soon.
Many civilizations have ended,
and ours is no different.
And if our awakening to this truth
is not strong enough,
our actions will not be strong enough
to heal ourselves
and to protect our Earth.
We need to see the suffering, the truth,
in order to get the awakening.
There's a deep connection
between the two.
We can't help if we're numb
or if we're overwhelmed.
Only when we dare to feel in our body
what all these facts,
all this information means,
will we truly awaken
to the preciousness of life.
And to the danger we are in.
And we have the spiritual strength;
we need to do this.
Mindful breathing and walking
can give us stability and non-fear.
Being in contact with nature
lifts our spirits and heals our soul.
The Earth, our ancestors
and our descendants,
they are all here with us in this moment.
Giving us clarity to see the truth
and courage to take radical loving action.
And with this awakening
and this spiritual strength,
it is possible for us to act
with the urgency of today
and also with the freedom of eternity.
Thank you.
(Applause)